it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
all right Raymond while Trump was
indicted the White House was keeping
Biden out of sight
yeah but the media could not have been
more excited Laura watch the president
is spending his evening with dinner in a
movie he just wrapped up dinner with the
first lady at a local seafood restaurant
and now he's at a movie theater watching
Oppenheimer
and that's what the Press pool asked him
about Laura how did you like Oppenheimer
meanwhile it was as if the Obamas had
returned to the White House and date
night was back there were pictures of
the bidens at dinner and even the
Biden's Moonlight stroll was covered I
wonder what the president was thinking
there's a you know an elderly man or
woman knowing they're waiting to see if
they have enough time just grabbing
their hand and walking across it's a
little tiny thing but it the anxiety it
relieves
all right they had to keep him out of
sight they had to totally keep him out
of sight as Trump was indicted because
they wanted the whole Hunter narrative
to die down and boy did it now it's all
about Oppenheimer and Moonlight strolls
Raymond I'm surprised someone didn't
throw a sandbag in front of my I mean
that's hard to navigate that's his
really small walkway there I wouldn't
have done that to the president you've
got to give him a lot a lot more light
than that Raymond a lot more light
they're holding his hand and Secret
Service is close by but while Dr Jill
was posing for magazine covers back in
D.C Laura the president's sister Valerie
Biden Owens his political Muse was asked
if she thought Meghan Markle might be
presidential Timber watch this
it's wonderful to have women in politics
and we embrace all women and we welcome
her to come in and join the Democratic
party so you think she'll make a good
potential candidate one day maybe for
president yes perhaps of course she will
Laura yeah she can do for the United
States which you did for the royal
family this is one of the most loathed
woman in pop culture Spotify and Netflix
killed deals with her and now she's
going to be president I guess
by the way Valerie Biden looks a lot
like Jane Fonda a little she looks like
or she looks like a combination of Jane
Fonda and Judge Judy if you mix those
two that's Valerie Biden that's all I
can say all right Raymond someone should
tell her though that they already have a
Democrat female understudy of color and
it's not Megan
yeah yeah well don't worry while Joe's
on vacation Kamala has been hitting the
interview circuit and it has been
hitting her
there are reports that say that you have
the lowest approval rating of any vice
president I'm curious how much of a role
if any that you feel race and gender
play in that well there are polls that
also say I have great approval ratings
oh Laura that must be the Harris poll
the Kamala Harris poll every poll has
her in the basement look I pulled this
NBC 49 uh they have a negative view of
the vice president 39 percent a very
negative View and the Monmouth poll 53
percent disapproval you got to work to
get that low sorry there are no upsides
to the polling numbers the only question
is what does Willie Brown say all right
um tell us about lizzo being sued by
three of her backup dancers because
America wants to know about this story
Randall well it's an important story
remember when lizzo was casting dancers
for her stage show it became a reality
program called watch out for the big
girls
I'm looking for dancers to join me on my
tour girls that look like me don't get
representation we thick and we pretty
and we know but we doubt it's hard to
love yourself in a world that doesn't
love you back you were created
especially in your image for you to
enjoy watch out for the big curls
well Laura if you believe the
allegations by lizzo's backup dancers
they'd better watch out for one big girl
in particular one who was fat shaming
them I just had this feeling that they
had a problem with the way I was gaining
weight she would pick and choose when
she wanted to be professional and when
she wanted things to be personal she
proceeded to say you know dancers get
fired for gaining weight you should
basically be grateful to be here you go
from preaching about Sisterhood to then
turning around and saying that it's a
privilege that you know us by name
boy is this this is actually a huge
story there's also part of the charge
here Laura is that lizzo coerced these
women to go into sex clubs and and
interact with nude models it's a wild
allegation we don't want to bring it all
up during the family hour but the
through line here is lizzo pushing body
positivity and yet fat shaming her own
dancers this would be like LeBron James
shaming somebody for being too tall I
mean come on lizzo is not exactly you
know
Twiggy here uh you know to be to be fat
shaming these poor dances now I mean for
the five people who know that reference
in our audience Twiggy can you come to I
mean Kate Moss can you come up with
something better than Twiggy something
in this Century that's right oh my God
it's about damn time that lizzo come
clean and apologize to these dancers but
this is a bag for somebody who's made
her career on this all right we gotta go
thank you rem hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else